you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from round one of the 2019
alts box Norway chess tournament on the
white end Magnus Carlsen and he's paired
against Vishy Anand this is their
armageddon game they drew their
classical game and so for the format of
this tournament that's what sparked the
Armageddon game here's a nice shot of
them in action photo courtesy of Leonard
Otis the official photographer of the
event doing well to capture a couple
endings here this is from their
classical game rook and pawn ending
moments before Anand plays h6 Greece
York looking on and it also tells the
story of how ding Liron defeated Wesley
so in their Armageddon game capturing
that final move okay this game here we
have an English opening the Bishop b4
noted as the kramnik sheer out
counter-attack given the chance maybe
black gives why CC pons not in this game
the knight jumps in Bishop backs off and
white plays this as if there is already
a minor piece imbalance and so cracks
open the position it's true that by
capturing on d4 here black is bringing
one of the white pieces into play
helping white to develop a piece but
black will gain a tempo back shortly
Knight f6 six moves in now minor piece
and bounds present and white is working
with now an unopposed bishop and
immediately putting it to work
coordinated pressure now on f6 serious
threat to chop away and give black
double isolated F pawns so how to cope
with this knight c6 Queen backs off
maintains pressure and now 95
interfering with the Queen seeing f6
here Knight f3 it may be tempting now
playing as black to capture on f3
preparing to meet Queen takes Knight
with let's say Queen B 4 check and maybe
C for false but Knight takes Knight
would not be good because white will
simply take with the Jeep on white is ok
in other words with having doubled F
pawns White will gladly follow with
Queen side castles have a nice cozy home
immediate rook activity and also enjoy
nice coordinated pressure on the dark
squares g7 will soon become sensitive
black will always be sensitive some on
the dark squares with this guy round so
not a good idea to welcome this
coordinated pressure
okay instead we have black opening up
the bishops eyes white likes that idea
as well and there is a question black
must answer how to get out of this pin
let's see h6 white keeps the pin and
sometimes the solid way out of this pin
solid meaning you know the way to break
the pin without making a concession with
your structure without playing g5 is to
put the knight on g6 and say back off
bishop go to g3 but in this particular
case again the knight has the
responsibility to shield the Queen from
seeing f6 so Knight g6 here white chops
away and yeah this is what black wants
to avoid
if in this position the Queen was on c2
this would be a nice solid way out of
the pin not here though in this game g5
preparing to meet the move Bishop g3
with Knight e4 and what do we have here
well the bishop is officially hunted so
white first takes on e5 believe it or
not move 12 is already a critical moment
in this game this next decision will set
the stage for the rest of the game black
to move what is the best move here feel
free to pause the video okay in the game
on takes Knight what is best however is
Knight to e4 hitting the Queen and let's
have a look at a couple variations from
here after Knight to e4 if white simply
reacts to this threat black will take
the knight still beyond this bishop and
have the move Queen a5 white will soon
have to go on Castle
okay well suppose in this position the
White Queen doesn't react instead we
have this move considered one of the
better moves for white in this position
looks a little crazy each side ignoring
one another's threats considered best
here is basically this Queen exchange
where at the end of the day what we're
going to have is this Bishop being
hunted by the knight this is all
extremely important I'm not just sharing
this variation for fun again this is
setting the stage for the rest of the
game what happens in the game is pawn
takes Knight and now once Bishop g3 is
in there there is no longer time for
Knight to e4 Knight e4 will be met with
Queen takes pawn game over it's not just
the win of a pond this is game over
after Bishop g3 Black has to now go on
the defensive address this threat
against e5 the bishop will live and be
an amazing piece so what do we have from
here white looks to open up the rook
break the dark squares down some black
does not want the position to open up
plays g4 c5 grabbing some Queen side
space if this pawn is picked off it's no
good because of Queen takes Knight takes
and white not only regains the pawn but
will soon win upon c7 this pawn is
poison
h5 rook c1 now you just can't take it
from here c6 given a chance maybe white
would just push and blast open the
queenside structure right just making a
dummy move c6 and what do we have split
pawns isolated pawns
okay c6 buy black Bishop d3
kingside castles King side castle and
rook to e8 so the Knights gonna have to
move black needs some defense some
additional defense over e5 before this
Queen side we can say gets developed so
to pieces now on e5 and rook to d1 so
all the white pieces contributing at
this stage the bishop on g3 is a really
strong piece for a couple reasons it is
an offensive and defensive piece I don't
see any way black is able to
successfully get at the White King with
this structure with this Bishop helping
to contribute I mean just picture the
bishop as if it's a pawn this is a super
solid King side structure whereas the
black pawns have drifted away from home
it's a little airy in blacks camp
okay from here Knight f6 Bishop to b1
preparing to set up a battery Knight d5
Queen c2 main to threat that shut down
with e4 but at the same time something
has been opened up the bishop size white
with these past few moves has been
successful
h4 this battery here forming generating
this threat against h7 it's forcing
these black pawns right we had black
pawns just a moment ago on e5 and g5
well they took a step forward and now
the dark squares are that much more
vulnerable and blacks camp in particular
d6 the bishop has a wonderful post on
that Square and if given the chance the
rook would love to pivot there as well
severely weakened now the dark squares
are severely weakened now in blacks
position so how does play proceed from
here it is first rook a d4 preparing to
double on the D file not just that
paving the way for maybe b-form okay
white would like to have this position
open up a bit more and it can it will on
the Queen side this is where black is
strong on d5 okay the additional in
additional point behind rook to d4 not
just a double it's threatening now e4
so that's defended all of the black
pawns have now drifted from the king
from here a three multi-purpose Bishop
eyes the eyes up the a to square the
b-pawn is ready to roll
so white is doubled here we go
b4 on board can only be prevented for so
long b5 is going to happen this is a
huge focal point as soon as this Knight
moves something's gonna jump in there
the rook is going to jump in there and
this Bishop again can't really say
enough about it it's doing a world of
good it's going to one day support upon
on the d6 square white is now gearing up
for b5
can play it right away after take stakes
you cannot take back in the game
it is Knight f6 and the rook slides into
d6 if you take in this position white
can play Bishop d6 cutting off two key
defenders of the night the night will
fall next so that would be a nice
interference move
we don't have captures on b5 but rather
Knight f6 rook d6 saying if you take my
rook I'm gonna take with the pawn thank
you very much for the past pawn
basically feels like a connected past
pawn normally only say that a protected
past pawn connected past pawn pretty
you'd have to be protected by hip on the
bishop is a wonderful piece Bishop's are
exchanged Queen f6 or Queen f7 keep the
Queen's on or not on White has the safer
King this right here is now Queen takes
rook picking up two rooks for the Queen
rook takes pawn takes Queen d7 some more
exchanges some more files are opening up
white makes use of it immediately
rook f8 Queen c7 I thought just a moment
ago I said keep the Queen's on you have
the safer King well it's a different
story here Queen takes Queen pawn is of
course recapturing and how are you
stopping this guy he is just way too far
advanced rook b8 and c8 would be nearby
so you can't take the Queen you really
can't do anything here is black but sit
and wait
it's just a slow slow death rook have
seven Czech Bishop to e5 and not too
much to do here Knight d5 Czech Queen to
b8 the white pieces are officially
swarming in this pawn is past but it's
just too far away from posing any
serious threat to team white so from
here we have Knight f6 Bishop takes
Knight rook h6 King e5 and from here
final move of the game is Queen 2h a
black resigns if rook to g7 you can pile
away at the pinned rook and liquidate
because you are pushing through one
final note is if you really wanted to do
things in the very best way this is
actually a checkmate into position
instead of Queen h7 the Queen could also
go to be too
and here for checkmate but there's only
a couple minutes on the clock
right about a couple minutes on the
clock for each of the players at this
stage so if you see one good move and
yeah that's good enough queen to H a and
this one does the trick
black ends up resigning don't forget how
we got to this point the early middle
game decision this is a forty three move
game right move twelve the decision
unmoved twelve is what set the stage for
the rest of the game this is what
allowed white to play for two results
there was never any fear of white attack
or black excuse me attacking the white
king that Bishop on g3 was enormous
wonderful defender attacker supporting
the pawn black did not find the best way
forward on that move twelve did not find
a way or didn't appreciate how important
it was I guess we can say to have the
knight be exchanged for that dark square
bishop didn't play that Knight to e4
move and that dark square bishop really
controlled the whole game we can say if
we have a look at the tale the tape with
this one here we go and we can see that
this right here was in fact the key
moment after Knight takes e5 and the
knee-jerk reaction right just
immediately recapture with the pawn was
in fact not a good choice allowed the
dark square bishop to live and it was
yeah white playing for either a win or a
draw no risk of a loss in this one final
tally here inaccuracies mistakes and
blunders three zero zero for Carlsen
three for one Anand average sent upon
loss sixteen and forty one the lower the
number the better
okay as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye
you